- The joke is out here, you know,
well this is where the wagon broke down
and Dad didn't have enough
money to get us on west.
- [Narrator] Four hours from anywhere,
in the heart of America's bread basket,
is a city fighting for better.
(acoustic guitar music)
To see the future of America,
Modelo looks not to its
coast, but to its heart.
It's there where we
found a place that proves
it doesn't matter where you come from,
it matters what you're made of.
- The people out here have
an attitude of working.
If you wanna work hard, this
is the area to do it in.
I moved out here 30 years ago
with not much more than
the shirt on my back.
Then the families out here
took me and my family in.
We're all transplants.
Everybody in Garden City's
from someplace else.
- The reason why I came
to the United States
is the violence back home.
I was 13 years old, you know,
and I seen a lot of bad stuff happening.
I see people getting killed.
You know, since the first day I
got here, I felt free.
- I'm from Somalia.
Back in my country, there was
a lot of civil war going on.
You just go in the town and
you're scared to get hurt.
You know I'm here, and I
decided to be here for my life,
so I wanna have more
people, more communities,
difference, you know, making big change to the city.
I have still my family back in Somalia.
I wanna have my family come with me.
There's no way I can forget about them.
- When you start with
no money, it is tough,
to come to different town.
You don't know what's going on.
Sometimes it's gonna be
hard, but not impossible.
Garden City is a good proof,
the things you can do
to be a successful person.
- Garden City is home.
It doesn't matter who you
are or where you come from,
the doors are open.
(speaking foreign language)
- People are people, we all
have the same wants and needs.
Garden City is constantly
fighting for better,
and I think if people just can see
that we're all just trying
to make it in this world.
It's just a lot easier to be accepting.
(speaking foreign language)
(cheering)
(Latin party music)
(ambient tone)